[Music]
this
is star talk neil degrasse tyson here
your personal astrophysicist
and it's sports edition star talk sports
edition
and today's topic is rowing uh gary
you're there
i'm naming all right good former soccer
pro former commentator
uh no you're a current commentator with
us former soccer commentator i'm still
broadcasting don't worry
okay i'm out there polluting the
airwaves okay
and chuck always good to have you dude
oh it's a pleasure man
we can ask the question is rowing the
exclusive purview
of prep schools and new englanders
or is the time overdue
to broaden that base it's all about the
base
welcome my guests for this segment our
shay arshay cooper welcome to star talk
sports edition
thanks for having me archie before we
begin do you have a
a a a social media handle that you want
to share with everybody
yes at r shay cooper on instagram and on
twitter
that simple there it is a-r-s-h-a-y
yeah you spelled it out okay
all right excellent so you're a rowing
coach and you won the benjamin
franklin award for your writing
is was it for a book called sugar water
is that did i say that right
yeah it was a book called sugar water
but changed the name to a most beautiful
thing
oh wow i kind of like water i kind of
like sugar
sugar sugar watermelon sugar
watermelon sugar so you also you're also
a motivational speaker and an activist
and you're the force behind is is it a
movie documentary
a most beautiful thing and it's the true
story of the first
all black high school rowing team
wow what were you saying how does that
even happen
is that like the jamaican bobsled team
what were you
thinking i know i got a lot of messages
of people saying cool rowings i was like
by the way guys by the way uh stay tuned
for rha's
next documentary the first downhill
slalom
all black high schools
[Laughter]
i'm just saying you know maybe some
sports
god never intended right
yeah yeah especially after a certain
period in history it's just like look
how many two black guys are getting this
boat and start ruin
excuse me i'm sorry no
no someone will be yelling commands at
you while
all right so who so tell me about this
story it's it's so
uh it's so even unbelievable that it's
it's amazing for how unbelievable
it is so go for it yeah you know i you
know i went to manly high school on the
west side of chicago
at the time it was the second most
violent high school in the city of
chicago and
i remember walking into the lunchroom
one day and i seen this boat this boat
was beautiful
and you know and i stopped and stared at
it and this little white lady came up to
me and she said hey
you want to be a part of the crew team
i'm like crew like you know you talk
you know if someone take you to join a
crew turn around and run the other way
as fast as you can
like you know i'm confused you know and
behind
but i'm also confused that there's a
rowing shell
and and in the lunchroom that's a little
weird to me but go on
so you know i'm actually stuck on that
right now but yeah keep going
that's why i stopped being scared and so
behind the boat was the tv monitor and
they were showing the olympic games
and and they said this sport would give
you an opportunity to travel
and although at that time it seemed like
an opportunity
no one in those images reflect the world
i was used to
so i said no and i walked away like
nobody signed up
and so i showed up the next day this
time it says if you sign up you get free
pizza and so there's a long line
as a commodity oh my gosh
i know it's we're doing the same thing
with vaccinations now
it's great it's great it works i'm a
pepperoni exactly
that's the other line
[Laughter]
yeah and so you know i you know i go up
aft you know to the info session after
school and all these young people
sitting on the floor
and you know i i saw a black coach and
so i was like wow
like there's a black coach in this sport
you know that
showed me right away that you know maybe
i'll be protected in this this space
that's different from
from me you know and uh they gave this
amazing
speech about the power of rowing and the
opportunity to travel and i remember
saying myself wait a minute there there
are no cheerleaders
there's no busload of fans there are no
million dollar contracts after college
right i don't know if i want to do this
right and did they did they tell you
about the uh getting out in the water at
five o'clock in the morning
they did not tell me that oh they did
not tell you that they didn't tell me
that
but i tell you but the moment you know
so
we joined we joined the team we started
to learn how to swim a little bit
and fast forward we get on the water
first time we get on the water
no one moved like you know i'm talking
about these were guys who who
probably carried a nine before they were
crying in the boat like
and i talked about it in my book and the
coach told us pull them back in
we did not move and so we go back in i
saw the disappointment on the coach's
face
the next day we go back we show up we
push out to open water in the middle of
chicago
and it was so crazy because the same
the survival mode that kicked in that
the same survival mode that usually
tells
us if you hear a gunshot run told us if
you want to get back to the dock safely
you have to pull for each other
and in order to pull for each other you
have to shut up and listen
and there's only one person talking and
they saying sit tall
breathe you belong here right and that's
when we begin to feel the magic
in the boat as we rolled by pairs and
the other pair
and and and that was the beginning of
something amazing because
you know i tried out for football but
the i experienced a lot growing up and a
lot of fights and
gunshots and all that stuff and and um
so i tried out for football but
the it triggered a lot of trauma so i
always wanted to fight like the impact
of someone to try to hurt me or
trying out basketball was the trash
talking sport and i wasn't good at it
and so i would hear things like you're
garbage and you suck and
um and i wanted your life and your
response was that's not nice
i wanted to fight but the fact that this
sport was like non-combative
not conflict right and before it became
a sport of competitiveness
it was a sport of meditation it was
rhymnic we were downloading that
serenity
and it was truly like calming those
storms inside of us
and um and that's when i kind of fell in
love
with the sport it silenced the noise for
me you had to grab a dimension of what
that sport was
encapsulate it and then bring it not
only to yourself
but to others who had the same
skepticism you did when you first
encountered
that sport absolutely absolutely
so for both of you neil too because neil
cruz
and or did you know and um
how much of this is mental in terms of
uh when you are in that kind of
meditative
state this rhythmic because it's such a
rhythmic sport
it's so about timing like as a comedian
it's one of the sports that you look at
and you really appreciate
because it really is about timing
everything from the
stroke to the turning of the ore to
everything to the placement in the water
to you know the synchronicity with your
teammates so
where does that what's going on in your
brain
when all that stuff is having to happen
there's only one answer
90 percent of the sport is half mental
[Laughter]
that's my mathematics right there see
that's the kind of mathematics i can
understand
i mean ashay you you talk about and
when i've read the things and listen to
the things you said about looking
backwards while you're moving forwards
and what that kind of meant to you as a
rower as a coach
as now an influencer in in a in a youth
community
yeah so i i wrote uh in my book that in
in
you know in crew i learned that it's
okay to look back
as long as you keep moving forward
because that's what the sport is all
about
and i think that you know for me uh we
had a hard time
uh really letting go the the life we
lived
and and while we navigated through this
this white sport and so
it was really the sport really kind of
honestly taught my whole team that like
hey
there's we we've been through a lot but
the important lesson here is that we
keep pushing forward and that
we can't do the work of eight but we
need eight people to do the work
and we'll get there much faster and
that's what we learned in the sport of
rowing and that's the lessons that
we bring um to many communities as we
start run programs all over the country
wow so tell me about your movie the yeah
it's a doc
it's a documentary the most beautiful
most beautiful thing yeah it's the most
beautiful thing it's um
uh narrated by common produced by dwayne
way
mary mazzio and um night wander
and i guess the request for me to
narrate it that was maybe i didn't get
get it yet it's still in my box
in my inbox yeah you know he was on you
was on the
yeah you was on the l it was morgan
freeman first
i'm gonna give you that
i'll never forget the day
okay so uh so is it out where can we
find it yeah so you can find it on
amazon
prime you can find it on peacock and
it's honestly it's our story from
beginning to end not just our story
but the story of our moms and in the
work that we're doing now in the city of
chicago through the support of rowing
so when back in the movie you make a
comeback you and the team
dust off those doors and come back 20
years later
why because our kids never
seen us row in a parent no no that's not
the reason
it's because someone invented advil over
that period of time
[Laughter]
it was a lot of pain a lot of crabs
it was painful it was painful but you
know we did it for the moms they never
got a chance to see us race because they
work in doubles or they wasn't around
and uh this story we really reached the
world in a different way and so
we wanted to put on a show for them and
and all the other uh chicago folks who
never
did it have an effect on the kids did it
actually change their perception
of you and the sport absolutely
absolutely
absolutely i mean they needed to see
someone like them that's out there
pulling hard and
and overcome we overcame you know we
overcame the fear of water
uh we traveled so many states as young
people and
and 90 it was growing in the
entrepreneurship team so 90
of my teammates are entrepreneurs and
started companies
on the uh west side and south side of
chicago wow so that did you guys ever do
dagvale when you were
competing because now i'm from philly
and a lot of people don't know that
philly
is a huge huge rowing town very quietly
kept
if you're from philly you you know this
sport because
every year one of the biggest
competitions
takes place on the school kill river and
uh
the opening scene to trading places is
rowers on that river in philadelphia
oh wow movie knowledge neil yes
look at that did you ever do that
the large part of our film was going to
philly and rowan in rome that's
that was our first out of town trip was
going to philly we spent a week there on
the school
and we rode out of the penn boathouse
sweet man that's very very cool
very cool so what you've done is you
have turned
rowing into a philosophy for life
philosophy for life you have the lessons
of working together pulling together
leaving the boathouse better than you
found the leaving the day
better than you found leaving the stroke
better you find it um you know and i
think the biggest
lesson was that philosophy is like you
know you can be like shaq
he will work on free throws for years
and never got better the one thing about
rowing
you sit on a machine and you get
stronger every time right you just get
better and so all those lessons that uh
we learned from the sport of rowing we
use it today and
and honestly we're launching nine new
programs
uh wrong programs this year um we have a
lot of young kids of color who who went
through the coll
who's going to college this year to row
and it and we believe that the sport
changed lives and to give you
an opportunity to really find peace in
the water if you you know
for all so i i'd like your initial
comment where
rowing is non it's competitive but
non-combative
this is a very important distinction and
there is
some trash talking and rowing but the
problem is
you don't really have extra breath to do
much talking
that's hilarious i would just love to
hear
wheezy trash you call that
[Laughter]
so we got to land this plane um or dock
this boat
uh what do you give me some take away
thoughts
get your motivational speaker motivate
us and our listeners just in whatever
way
comes organically out of you given your
life experience
yeah i will say this um for me the the
best lesson i learned in the sport was
outside of the uh the water and that was
to leave the boathouse better than you
found it
even if you didn't make the mess right
because it leaves it
it leaves it easier for the next group
that's coming in and our coach will say
it every day
and so my life has been how do i leave
the classroom how do i leave this
this podcast how do i leave my community
better than i found it even if i didn't
make the mess
and um and that's what it's all about
and we go into schools and we leave them
better than we found it and we can
control that and uh
and that's what i leave you with and if
you extend that up to all of
civilization
let the world be a little better for you
having lived in it but can i just add a
caveat to that ourselves no you can't he
just concluded
with beautiful words i gotta add a
caveat to that because i think it's such
a beautiful sentiment
leave it better than you found it even
if you didn't make the mess
but go find that dude that made that
mess
[Laughter]
and let that mother something know
because i'm not cleaning up past you no
more i'm serious
i love it i love it i love it i love it
i love it i love it i love it
rowing's non-combative
great to have you on this segment of
star talk sports edition
different strokes i'm neil degrassi
tyson chuck always good to have you
always a pleasure and gary always good
to have you archaic keep it going dude
yeah and i others saw the documentary
i'm gonna see it tonight
and i'm gonna be all over it and we're
gonna maybe we'll get you back on
um we'll talk some more rowing because
this is our first ever rowing show
and there's so much more to get into but
anyhow as it is i am neil degrasse tyson
you're a personal astrophysicist
as always
[Music]
you